[Aplausos]
quiero presentarles a esta niña hoy
porque de ellos es quien les voy a
hablar
cuando el familia tenía 11 años
vivió una de las escenas más
maravillosas de toda su infancia
por primera vez
llegaba a todo un equipo médico a esa
vereda alejada que en pocos mapas
colombianos existe
ese lugar maravilloso extraordinario de
almas de atardeceres de flora de fauna
y de mitos
que son propios de regiones como esa
donde creció esa niña
ese día por primera vez
había un médico un odontólogo un
optómetra
y también una psicóloga
y esta mujer
tenía su cabello dorado
en sus uñas iban unas flores
perfectamente dibujadas
y su rostro estaba perfectamente
maquillado
en ese momento
aún no sabía que esta psicóloga
se iba a convertir en mi mayor símbolo
cuando de feminidad se trataba
inicio la el chequeo médico
eran siete veredas aledañas quienes
participaban de la ocasión
obviamente el sancocho de línea no podía
hacerse esperar
había un equipo de recreacionistas
pero lo más importante de ese día era
que por primera vez a mi casa ha llegado
el niño dios
y esta psicóloga entre sonrisas ordenaba
que los niños hicieran fila a un lado y
los niños en el otro
y yo muy emocionada salgo pongo a mis
cuatro hermanas en la fila de las niñas
y a mis dos hermanos en la fila de los
niños y me retiro
porque por nada del mundo quería
perderme
esa sonrisa que muy seguramente se lleva
a dibujar en sus rostros
al recibir ese pequeño juguete pero que
era enorme porque nunca lo habían tenido
pero en el momento en que me voy
retirando se acerca esta mujer y me
pregunta
y tú por qué no haces la fila
y le contesto es que yo ya estoy grande
se aleja sin decir nada
obviamente me sentía grande porque para
ese instante era mamá y papá de seis
hermanos
y cuando regresa trae a una muñeca
paula
era persona
bajita y hoy que conozco de rapunzel su
cabello era igual
y debo confesar
y por unos instantes se me olvidaron mis
hermanos se me olvidó que quería ver la
sonrisa en sus rostros
porque el mundo desapareció hoy con ese
instante todas las responsabilidades que
para estos 11 años tenía
obviamente
se me quemaron muchos frijoles después
por estar atendiendo a paula
pero profesor que fue donde las
experiencias más maravillosas con las
que aún sonrío
para la fue
muy importante en mi niñez y mucho más
adelante en mi vida
pasaron unos meses
una tarde un 28 de febrero
de 1998
estaba en esa mesa de retazos de madera
sentada con un cuaderno un lápiz
plasmando todo ese sueño todas las
ilusiones que tenía de niña
y en ese momento esas ilusiones era que
quería ser psicóloga pero para ese
instante no sabía que la universidad
existía
creía que todo era así por arte de magia
que era tan fácil conocer esa amazónica
divina hermosa preciosa con todos los
superpoderes del mundo que siempre vivía
en mi imaginación
y obviamente paola estaba enfrente de mí
haciendo parte de toda esa fantasía de
ese momento
pero hay un momento en que aterrizó a la
realidad y no sólo estaba paola siendo
testigo de esa fantasía sino que también
un hombre moreno alto
un comandante de las farc
desde hacía tiempo atrás conocíamos y
hay que personalmente le tenía pavor
dijo varias palabras que para ese
momento no entendí
pero hay una última frase que se escucha
perfectamente y fue
a partir de ahora empiezas a ser parte
del conflicto a partir de ahora empiezas
a hacer parte de las farc
pues cambia mi falda larga por un
pantalón y cuando regrese este
comandante tenía paola en las manos
mientras en voz baja me decía se te verá
mejor un fusil
y ese día inicia mi vida en la guerra
ese día me dijo que sólo serían tres
meses tres meses que se convertirían en
años
ese día saliendo de mi casa entendí que
paola iba a ser la última imagen de mi
infancia de mi casa de mi hogar de mi
tierra de esa vereda que nunca más hasta
hoy ha podido volver a visitar
pero hoy no vengo a hablarles
de los sufrimientos ni de los negativos
que fue esa vivencia dentro del
conflicto y vengo a hablarles de esa
niña
esa niña
que un día estando en el conflicto
empieza a despertar y a darse cuenta que
con cada vez que alzaba su equipo de
tres a robas sus brazos iban cogiendo
músculo
que cada vez que participaba de un
entrenamiento sus piernas eran más
varoniles su espalda más ancha
y cada vez su rostro estaba más
envejecido por el sol
por las cargas emocionales
y porque ya no tenía sueños
hay un momento
en el que estoy en uno de los ríos
bañándome
y alzó la mirada y hay un hombre que me
mira de una forma totalmente diferente a
como me habían visto en algún momento de
mi vida
mi lectura en ese momento era cuántas
preguntas estar haciendo este hombre
y en medio de esa mirada que me hacía
murmura niña
niña
one soy una niña
era difícil entender que en medio de un
mundo tan masculino y tan grotesco y tan
duro como el del conflicto yo era una
niña
y empecé a pensar
soy una niña
como hago para verme una niña en medio
de tanto verde
en medio de todo este entorno como hago
para que me vean como una niña
la fe
la psicóloga tenía el cabello rubio
yo lo que necesito hacer es pintura del
cabello de rubio para verme femenina
pero como lo hacía en la selva no había
tinte
entonces este mismo hombre me dice
el agua oxigenada tintura del cabello
con la fortuna de que en ese instante yo
era enfermera del grupo de combate del
frente al que pertenecía
y muy curiosamente había un tarro de
agost y henna en mi equipo que por
cierto me tallaba cada vez que cargaba
y aún recuerdo a este hombre tintura
cndh o mi cabello
aún tengo las escenas en mi mente de
ponerle flores a mi equipo
y descolgar pequeños objetos que me
representarán lo que era ser mujer para
que no se me olvidará
porque ya se me había olvidado mi nombre
es real porque ya había perdido toda mi
identidad lo único que me quedaba en
este momento era rescatar mi feminidad
y empecé a entender que era frágil que
era tierna que era dulce que era
sensible que necesitaba que me
protegiera
pero hay un momento donde en medio de
uno de los combates
sufro un accidente que me deja
totalmente parapléjica
durante unos meses
y dependía totalmente de mis compañeros
dependía de si comía si me bañaba de de
cada cosa mínima cotidiana del día a día
de mis compañeros y llegué a ese límite
decir más
pero también entendí que a los 8 años
había quedado
a cargo de seis hermanos y que habían
salido adelante con ellos
a pesar de que nunca fue mi sueño cargar
un fusil tenía una hoja de vida
impecable dentro del conflicto
y empiezo a hacer un análisis
de todas esas pequeñas cosas que había
superado en mi vida y dije de aquí me
levanto
y empecé a recordar a un comandante
mientras me golpeaba que me decía que
todo en la vida era psicológico
empecé arrastrándome
cat
unos días después camine
y ahí entendí que no solo era frágil
tierna dulce
sino que también era una mujer fuerte
con una fuerza superior a mí que podía
lograr lo que fuera que me propusiera
hace un tiempo
cansada del conflicto
una niña menor a mi un año un día me
dice vámonos
no es esto lo que queremos
y dije
me veo débil
es menor que yo era tímida esa mujer no
hablaba
pero fue increíble como al unirnos
sacamos las fuerzas de correr tres días
dos noches hasta llegar por primera vez
a una ciudad
y empezar a sobrevivir en esa ciudad
empezar a enfrentarte contra el mundo
sin educación sin conocer nada ni a
nadie sin ningún tipo de red
cuando hace un televisor a mis 17 años
para mineral jugó sino el fútbol
jamás en la vida
había elegido el color de mi ropa y no
saben lo maravilloso que se siente
no se imaginan lo importante que fue
para mí tomar esa primera lección
entonces años después
soy empleada
soy madre de dos princesas maravillosos
que me enseñan el valor de la vida cada
día
soy estudiante
soy una ciudadana común y corriente
que aprendió a reconstruir sus sueños o
tal vez a rescatarlos porque nunca dijo
que se los arrebataron
dos años después
vuelve a creer en hadas un y cortos cada
vez que veo las películas infantiles con
mis hijas
ahí me llaman la mujer de los siete
nombres porque he tenido siete nombres
diferentes siete identidades diferentes
todos con algo en común fuerza valor y
residencia
hoy
agradezco cada una de las vivencias que
viví
porque aprendí el valor y el poder de
contar mi propia historia y de lo que
podía generar en muchas más personas
he tenido espacios y escenarios
maravillosos en los que anteriormente
esas personas que han estado sentadas a
mi lado muy seguramente nos hubiésemos
enfrentado por la vida
hoy desde una herramienta diferente
construimos escenarios de paz y de
reconciliación
hoy hago parte de una entidad en donde
lideró proyectos sociales en donde las
niñas madres adolescentes son mi
prioridad y la labor más hermosa que
puedo hacer en la vida
quiero preguntarles
qué tan poderosa creen ustedes que puede
ser su historia
y que creen que pueden lograr con ella
en otras personas
hoy está aquí kinect la niña que soñó
con ser mujer sin permitir que le
arrebataran nunca ni nadie sus sueños
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]